on
diagonal l'actualité internationale du
jeu d'échecs émission spéciale veille
tandis puisque c'est l'actualité de la
semaine avec deux invités exceptionnels
j'ai à ma droite jean-luc modesto
chabanon bonjour jean luc bonjour et loi
donc tu reviens de vie choquant dit nous
avons passé deux jours là bas faire un
reportage donc tes impressions
en quelques mots sur ce tournoi bien
c'est un tournoi fantastique c'est le
plus fort thomas de tous les temps il y
avait neuf meilleurs joueurs du monde et
il ya aussi la rencontre entre les
quatre les quatre ténors de l'actualité
à l'international c'est à dire garry
kasparov l'animal femmes nick wichmann
d'alternants et alexei shirov quatre
excellents joueurs qui font partie donc
et évidemment du top mondial
nous avons également dans cette émission
le jeune laurent frayssinet numéro 5
juniors mondiale quand soir le rend dans
soirée loi donc se tendent à vue tandis
tu l'a suivi sur internet
alors ton analyse qui va gagner le
tournoi à ton avis à mon avis et bons
kasparov est évidemment bien partie vu
qu'il reste plus que deux parties et 20
points d'avance ce qui est quand même
assez énorme et comme on le voit pas
perdre tous les jours même s'il fait
deux nuls et que son poursuivant ses
poursuivants gagner deux parties il
finira premier ex-aequo et je le vois le
gros favori maintenant grand favori
maintenant donc à sport favori
effectivement tous les ténors sont là
sans plus tarder on va commencer avec
des images donc des images de la salle
de l'ensemble on va vous présenter un
petit peu les joueurs qui avaient dans
le tournoi et voilà donc feu pour les
images donc là nous avons vassily
ivanchuk
le célèbre joueur vif manhattan ah non
deux joueurs indiens qui est en train de
lire le bulletin
yann timan la star hollandaise qui nous
vient de hollande et donc des pays bas
qui est donc le héros local dire une
piquette connais bien également michael
adams wade jean luc tu le connais bien
c'est un ami à toi oui c'est un ami
c'est quelqu'un de très très très gentil
qui voit là très décontracté donc là
c'est la partie qui commence à nantes
contre topalov donc ces grosses parties
et là nous avons le champion du monde
james l'a dit mercredi qu' qui pour ce
tournoi ne s'habillait pas avec les
tenues qu'on lui connaît habituellement
c'est à dire qu'il était plus détendue
match hollande au hollandais le xv
novelli contre yann timan ici la star
montante morozevich numéro cinq mondial
actuellement extrêmement fort et qui se
comporte pas mal dans le tournoi
puisqu'il est pour l'instant deuxième
ex-aequo l'atvs yaakov qu'ils soient
comportement bien puisqu'il est dernier
ex aequo c'est moins bon naples en
travers et là pour finir le king le
grand gary legrand gary très très
méchant alors on va voir ses mimiques
habituelles
il a l'air méchant là où la junte et le
diable une noyade
étrange et là il va s'étouffer comme
d'habitude avec sa cravate un n aime pas
inapte à ce moment-là garé il enlève son
autre cravate rose c'est toujours
délicat
ça y est il s'en est sorti ce que tu
oublies préciser c'est que pour cette
partie garry kasparov est venu je crois
avec avec 8 minutes de retard huit
minutes de retard mais c'était la partie
contre peter l'écho il simule admire
chronique sur un fond d'échiquier mais
que la dame sur un fond des filets
également puisqu'ils ont des décors à
eux
et voilà l'envoya l'open également avec
donc tout un paquet de joueurs
y'en a plus de six ans qui joue cet open
et la décoration final donc de cette fin
de tournoi voilà donc ces quelques
images de présentation du tournoi
on va vous donner le classement actuel
donc après laurent 11 rondes
tout à fait kasparov en tête donc est ce
que c'est une surprise ou pas puisque
maintenant il est à paris mais je ne
pense pas que ce soit une surprise vu
que le les tonnelles et on m'a fermé et
les matchs sont deux choses bien
différentes
et ce avec un match bon il a perdu son
premier match contre vladimir kramnik
mais ça quand on va fermer
ça fait deux ans qu'ils gagnent tous les
tournois du top niveau et c'est pas
étonnant de le retrouver en forme après
son match contre à munich
à noter que shirov lui a posé des
problèmes puisqu'il avait un point
d'avancé sur kasparov
oui mais quand on regarde les
appariements on peut s'apercevoir que
shirov avait les meilleurs joueurs a
rencontré sur la fin et dont c'est vrai
que c'est au début il a rencontré les
joueurs un peu plus faible et c'est vrai
que maintenant il a entraîne non
seulement une à thabo difficile et en
plus il est en train de craquer donc ça
va être très dur pour nous il est en
train de craquer alexei shirov il a pas
les nerfs solides
jean-luc le tournoi est très très
difficile je l'air solide ou pas d'un
solide je pense que kasparov et très
régulier et alexei à des problèmes pour
le pour le suivre alexa ya des problèmes
pour le suivre non mais c'est vrai que
kasparov fait quand même office de deux
très fort joueur c'est une valeur sûre
garry kasparov même si en ce moment il
un peu controversé suite à ses multiples
défaites dont kasparov huit points sur
11 mai point sur on s'est quand même un
gros score c'est
6 nuls 5 victoires donc c'est ça des
joueurs les tout meilleurs mondiaux donc
c'est vraiment très impressionnant suivi
celui d'après alexei shirov est morose
et beach avec 7 points
donc mon rêve et je suis en train de
revenir moi au début qu'on connaît pas
bien mais bon qui est quand même très
jeunes très bon choix
oui tout à fait et moi on the beach sur
toile noire il a fait des résultats
excellents et des noirs et 5 ans pour
comparis ch est en fait moins évident
parce qu'ils ont un peu le même même
style pays prennent beaucoup de risques
à tous les deux et hyper beau il permet
beaucoup plus de parties que kasparov
mais il en gagne aussi plus donc c'est
vrai que this is an est-il intéressant
ici un tournoi qui réussit apparemment
aux joueurs gambling puisque shirov est
morose abidjan qu occupe la 2è et 3è
places qui est pas mal
suivent ensuite chronique anand et yvan
de choucas 6 points et demi ensuite on à
adams qui rate un petit peu là qui vient
de perdre une partie
peter l'écho cinq points c'est la
mauvaise performance de ce tournoi
topalov fait d'europe vendredi etc
on va demander l'avis d'un joueur qu'on
a rencontrés là-bas jean-luc il s'agit
d'une grand maître international belge
lounguine ans
oui numéro 1 belge donc dans un instant
donc qui nous as donné son avis donc sur
sur la compétition voilà alors on va
l'envoyer le queens lente bonal
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
nous sommes donc en direct de vice kenzy
et j'ai donc le plaisir de deux
d'invités donc monsieur louis luc oui
wind grand maître international belge
donc qui va nous parler donc de ce
tournoi donc bonjour l'udc bonjour jean
luc donc luc donc voilà qu'est ce que tu
penses un petit peu de ce plus fortement
de tous les temps et et de la période
actuelle où il est joué donc ou qui est
le meilleur joueur de la planète
alors cet internat magnifique bien sûr
avec la top 9 9 mondial plus encore van
walle qui est 12e donc il ya vraiment du
beau monde
c'est un peu un tournoi qui doit
déterminer le rôle de champion du monde
quelque sorte puisque on a trois joueurs
qui revendique cette position avec
kasparov numéro un au classement
chronique du vainqueur de kasparov et un
homme champion de la fédération
internationale ce qui fait que il y a
donc on attend impatiemment la fin du
tournoi pour que ses joueurs puissent
audimat départager il faut quand même
dire qu un an tu es dans une position
désavantageuse puisqu'il a dû jouer du
concurrent arrêté noir et qu'ils
viennent à peine de terminer ce tournoi
à new delhi et était rend donc il est
quand même assez fatigué il a dû révéler
une grosse partie de son répertoire avec
autant adversaire différent
voilà donc effectivement il ya les
joueurs ne partent pas libres et égaux
en droits pour ainsi dire dans ce
tournoi puisqu'il ya déjà les
appariements qui jouent et ensuite comme
les dates sont fixées les mêmes pour
tout le monde il ya des joueurs qui sont
plus fatigués que d'autres c'est
peut-être le cas effectivement de
wisches manhattan ondes qui a dû montrer
une grosse partie de son répertoire
comme l'a dit le clean ans je sais pas
ce que tu en penses laurent voulu tout à
fait je pense qu'à ce niveau là les
joueurs nouvelle assez souvent un
travail beaucoup d'encre nouvelle s est
pas vraiment un problème c'est plutôt à
mon avis au niveau de la fatigue et des
tensions nerveuses qui a pu avoir en
championnat du monde de sanud être assez
dur de récupérer aussi vite assez dur
effectivement en tout cas garry kasparov
lui a eu du temps il avait du temps et
en plus il était sur une défaite donc il
a dû être très très motivés ça joue
peut-être en sa faveur dans ce combat là
comme d'habitude toute façon même temps
et toit fermé quand on le voyait perdre
en général le lendemain on peut on peut
dire qu'il a perdu son match et donc le
temps après il n'a vraiment à coeur de
gagner au moins à coeur de gagner c'est
vrai que c'est la position de garry
kasparov en tant que numéro un mondial
jean-luc on l'a posée à pratiquement
tous les joueurs là-bas est quand même
assez controversé oui la position de
garry kasparov et controversé parce
qu'évidemment il vient de perdre ce
match contre vladimir kramnik et que et
que
wisches madame un nom a fait un résultat
fantastique donc au championnat du monde
en inde et à téhéran c'est ce qu'on va
voir donc dans les interviews qui vont
suivre
là on va avoir une piquette et lui un
avis bien particulier puisqu'il enlève
complètement shirov simplement de la
place de prétendant aux meilleurs
joueurs du monde donc pour lui en a que
3 c chronique à nombre et kasparov
c'est un avis qui al'air communément
partagée laurent est ce que tu es
d'accord avec cette joint venture enfin
jamais gagné bon il a battu cramique
d'accord mais s'est essayé à deux ans et
chronique c'est vrai a dit qu'il s'était
pas très bien préparés et c'est vrai que
quand on voit le match chronique celle
de 98 grammes ni kasparov de 2000 c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas l'impression devant
le même chronique
travnik et beaucoup progressé donc on va
voir tout de suite ironie piquette
nationale chez nous et l'ohio rhône
saône la négation alex hayes une série
fantastique monde
alex alice faire abattre les bêtes
il in india and jews of accelerating
votre rôle est encore un peu tôt le
maintien ok fait qu'il y aura
iron une piquette qui nous dit donc
quelque chose d'intéressant krasniqi
seconde ligne lot donc travnik prend des
risques et ça c'est ça qui lui permet de
marquer beaucoup de points donc la
douleur tragique soit-il un arnaqueur je
sais pas si c'est ce qu'a voulu dire en
tout cas l'admirent chronique serait
d'ampleur
enfin à la partie qu'on demande c'est
vite chassée lorna coeur en équipe on a
l'impression que il prend beaucoup de
risques et voilà et donc avant il permet
pas de parti et il s'est trouvé que 2.2
morose et 8 ch il a pris un peu trop
risqué et l'internet donc effectivement
je m'étais trompé piquette n'exclut pas
du tout shirov puisqu'il pensait que
c'était un des gros favoris de ce
tournoi s'il arrivait à ne pas se faire
enfumer tactiquement mais les sens
d'analysé correct il a dit que shirov ne
devait pas perdre deux parties et est
depuis sa défaite contre kasparov
on le sent un petit peu un petit peu à
la dérive un petit peu dans le doute
effectivement puisque il a perdu contre
kasparov cette fameuse partie
ensuite il a fait nul dans une position
gagnante contre allende et aujourd'hui
il vient de perdre contre je ne sais
plus y joue contre ivan de chaud quoi il
s'est fait tout simplement et exploser
voilà tout à fait donc il a fait venir à
l'ouverture mais bon c'est vrai que
c'est évident qu'à une austin qui l'aï
les risques qui prend s'il perd pas de
parti va gagner le tournoi ça c'est pas
besoin d'être ces systèmes ans et c'est
évident mais bon c'est vrai que je ne
serai peut-être que peurs d'une partie
celle déstabilise voilà tout est sur le
terrain'' ensuite tout interdisant et
gary six ans est inouï devant l'habitude
quand c'est arrivé
il a peut-être une partie non en tout
cas dire une piquette nous dit également
qu'il n'est pas en forme ça c'est vrai
puisque effectivement idée pour
l'instant dernier ex-aequo de ce
tournant active yaakov sur la nouvelle
cadence fi des gens que tu puisses que
tu l'a posé cette question
en fait il s'en fout il s'en fout pas
vraiment on va dire que ce qui
l'intéresse donc dans la nouvelle
cadence c'est d'utiliser cette cadence
donc dans les compétitions par équipes
comme les olympiades ou
comme les compétitions sont très très
longue ça permettrait donc de raccourcir
la durée des compétitions mais de garder
l'ancienne cadence pour les très très
fort tournoi comme le tournage jusqu'en
asie et qui perdraient de leur charmant
voilà donc on a des avis très différent
des joueurs qui ont chacun leur avis on
va voir ça puisque topalov plus tard
aura une vie différente sur la question
on va enchaîner avec l'interview d'un
nouvel hollande et loïc van de walle qui
vient de passer au dessus de la barre
des 2700 points du lot
ivy international chez news oui une
version wii va mister visciano veut new
world champion saura et vichy yacine
newton oiseaux fantastique faut une
forte complicité des consommateurs
come back
probably où plus personne come back non
mais c'est ok
et non ce n'était pas vendu velits
c'était wichmann wisches manhattan
attendent le champion du monde de la
fidh est donc extrêmement fort on vient
poser la question du genre et que tu lui
as demandé ce qu'ils pensaient de cette
situation et chicken avec un champion du
monde brent games qui est donc
l'admirent krainik est un champion du
monde fis des sur quoi aucune réponse
simple il pense que la situation est
regrettable mais qu il n'y a pas
grand-chose à faire actuellement donc
les choses ne pourront pas évoluer
bientôt il envoie une petite pique aussi
il a pas dit que chronique été champion
du monde il a dit oui je le félicite
d'avoir battu kasparov en match c'était
sa réponse à ce championnat du monde
pointe games entre guillemets et sinon
pour sa situation dans le tournoi
l'auront il a dit qu'il n'était pas très
en forme qu'il avait plus sain que ce
n'était pas génial mais bon envoyer plus
un c'est pas génial mais bon les joueurs
sont tellement fortes c'est pas c'est
pas toujours évident si on n'a pas trop
d'énergie c'est pas c'est pas évident de
marquer beaucoup de points donc il a dit
qu'ils continuent à se battre et c'est
vrai que maintenant ils commencent à
revenir un peu et moi je le vois bien
terminé second du temps second du temps
alors qu'il l'a donc pour l'instant plus
de hilda 6 points et demi souvent
ex-aequo au point mort selon les échos
c'est une possibilité
or gagner une partie sur l'année
dernière oui ça c'est tout à fait
possible mais interne en il est là le
souffle mais l'on peut aussi espérer
donc peut-être peut-être plus chier
shirov qui a peut-être permis un petit
peu de son peps mais morose et vite
peut-être qu'il peut essayer de
rejoindre de caracoler à la première
place auprès de kasparov
oui morose et beach en attend beaucoup
de lui puisque là il vient de mettre le
turbo ou en tout cas on verra bien ça
sera dans la prochaine mission diagonale
vendredi prochain on va maintenant vous
montrez l'interview de loïc van de walle
cette fois ci c'est la bonne et on va
voir qu'il était peut-être un petit peu
il avait peut-être un petit peu bu
austin fairview aussi
la chasse aux ailes au look un bon jour
sow il y en aura trois nouveaux trails
in the world
so what is shown in front of you public
y habiter it it's fantastic you in
prouve la saison 2009 10 est votre point
de vue si twilight bella center de
houston de cette chronique une veste is
nothing in moun de fans de carrie ann
alex est probable il faut chaud
good for mme kouassi
gooch un défi à washington qui
trafiquent chronique morceaux de boeuf
par un anti se bat ripley chef caspar
vente d'un jeu
so what is you pronostics nos phobies ce
match tout mode kasparov en chef chez
office black avoir est fallu que tu as
fait surface verte résident les
toulougiens
allez donnerait donnant au québec f1 ok
vin qui vous fait voilà donc si je
regarde ta tête tu penses que shirov va
perdre c'est ce qu'a dit vendredi à la
question est ce que tu penses que
poursuivre la partie casper shirov de
demain donc d'avant-hier donc la partie
de fear of vandelli donc lafferty
castrophe shirov et bien on peut dire
que kasparov a mis les bouchées doubles
dans cette partie il a été très
impressionnant il a il a bien il ya bien
un sacré chez alexei shirov il ya bien
dans cet eric sèle shirov sur cette
interview devant le velly qu'est-ce
qu'on peut noter également et bien qu'il
se prend pas au sérieux
loïc mandelli puisqu'il à 2700 il est
12e mondial et il parle de my so called
newco l'igs qui veut dire mais
soi-disant nouveaux collègues
on a vraiment l'impression qu'il est là
par hasard et qu' il est là pour rigoler
quoi oui mais bon c'est quand même c'est
remarquable d'obtenir ce classement de
2700 envie d'y ans puisqu'ils entrent
dans les 12 meilleurs joueurs du monde
et et je pense que c'est peut-être le
premier joueur hollandais à y parvenir
oui effectivement c'est c'est une belle
performance sur son tournoi
qu'est-ce qui nous a dit d'intéressant
sur son tournoi gpj patron j'ai pas trop
compris ce qu'il a dit il y avait moi je
vois son tournoi c'est le bath se passe
moyennement il l'attend il attend de
voir comment ça va se passer
apparemment il a perdu il a perdu une
petite partie contre adams et depuis il
est un petit peu descendu au classement
mais bon il peut toujours revenir on
sait jamais il peut essayer de faire la
moyenne en tout cas oui ils vont devenir
à quatre et demi sur onze donc faire la
moyenne faudrait qu'ils gagnent les deux
dernières effectivement ce n'est pas du
tout en harmonie avec le classement qui
date de 1700 points donc une
contre-performance mais c'est pas très
grave puisqu'on sait tous plus ou moins
est lui aussi que ce classement est un
peu surévalué nos classes vont lever lit
quand même assez joyeux dans cette
interview on l'a vu
souriant humour ils jouent à domicile
il est détendu quoi voilà voilà donc un
joueur hollandais détendu alors
maintenant nous allons passer à
l'interview du numéro un français qui
est donc second temps de la douleur
chronique qui étaient là et là c'est
bien parce que justement il parle en
français joël lautier diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
nous sommes ici à wisches kenzy avec
joël lautier numéro un français bonjour
joël bonjour nous allons donc parler des
très très fort joueur qui sont dans ce
tournoi et des plus principalement des
quatre meilleurs joueurs au monde
oui donc effectivement on a une
situation intéressante maintenant parce
qu'on a trois joueurs je pense plus que
quatre on a trois joueurs qui peuvent
prétendre être le meilleur joueur du
monde à l'heure actuelle c'est kasparov
un nom des chroniques shirov a quand
même été battus largement par un an dont
final donc je pense pas qu'ils fassent
partie du groupe bien qu'ils mènent au
tournant ce moment mais je pense qu'il
est mais pas du même niveau
un nom n'est pas très en forme sur mon
fatigué après new delhi et était en et
puis gradnik joue bien je pense
il a raté quelques occasions de gagner
des parties qui leur a permis de partir
la première passe kasparov joue
correctement aussi donc on va voir ce
qui va se passer l'épaule les prochaines
rondes
bon évidemment un peu en avance pour
shirov c'est beaucoup mais je pense que
comme il est aujourd'hui il faut encore
qu'il joue kasparov avec les noirs et
ensuite il faut contre cramique ses
passions qui gagne le tournoi est
d'ailleurs quels sont tes pronostics
entre cette fameuse partie tant attendu
entre gary kasparov et alexei shirov je
pense que je pense que kasparov a gagné
voilà donc je voudrais aussi te poser
des questions concernant ton poulain
vladimir kramnik je voudrais savoir donc
là actuellement tué probablement en
train de le préparer et où est ce que tu
peux un petit peu d'où nous parler de
cette préparation
sommairement on va dire la préparation
il n'y a pas grand chose à dire c'est à
dire que je travaille avec lui le soir
la nuit tout seul et puis le matin on
revoit des trucs ensemble donc il ya
pour chaque adversaire il n'y avait pas
trois quatre ouvertures différentes à
préparer donc voila quoi le travail sus
en cours sans problème et tonton rôle de
second dans tu comptes le continuer
longtemps
je ne sais pas on verra pour l'instant
ça marche bien la dîmière a gagné allons
ici il joue pas tant de mal pour
l'instant donc s'il lui est content moi
pour l'instant c'est ça me convient tout
à fait c'est un travail très intéressant
donc il n'ya pas de raison que ça
s'arrête et quels sont tes projets à toi
pour pour l'avenir dans quel sens des
prochains tournois donc le gélat
nationale une bientôt en février déjà
et puis ensuite je vais jouer aussi à
cannes la coupe du monde deux parties
rapides un tournoi que que j'attends
beaucoup parce qu'il est une manière à
caspar a bien sûr il y aura les autres
il se trouve d'ailleurs c'est assez
amusant que kasparov et dans le groupe
où trois des joueurs qui ont travaillé
avec l'admirent pour la préparation du
match contre kasparov jouer avec lui
c'est là que j'y serai il y aura aussi
bas relief est issu de la donc je pense
qu'il va ailleurs une grosse ambiance
dans notre groupe donc il ya ça et puis
ensuite il ya aussi le tome 1 à enghien
qui a lieu cette année avec 1,4 y y et
17 probablement donc ce serait très fort
c'est donc un gary qui aura qui aura
peut-être des envies de revanche par
personne interposée donc beaucoup de
spectacle est garanti pour pour cannes
j'espère en tout cas bonne chance
un joël lautier qui étaient là bas
finalement en spectateur puisqu'il ne
participera pas au tournoi en seconde en
a peut-être on va se tourner vers
laurent quand même le roi joël lautier
synthé concurrents principaux pour la
place de numéro un français voilà tout à
fait enfin moi je ne vise pas tellement
ça
mon objectif est de progresser et donc
après si ça doit venir ça viendra démons
pas de problème et est-ce que tu
envisagerait un jour de te convertir en
tant que seconde ans comme l'a fait plus
ou moins joël puisque là il se gonfle à
divers trafics ils le suivent donc c'est
vraiment c'est je pense que secondaire
joueurs comme blagnac ramic ça doit être
je pense qu'on apprend beaucoup plus
quand je vois des toits en quinze jours
un petit tournoi ça doit être fabuleux
note d'analysé 15 juin si fort très très
enrichissant sans doute voyage en lui
c'est fabuleux et épuisant d'ailleurs
comme comme va nous le dire joue l île
taki le travail soit le soirée et la
nuit il travaille qu'à trouver assure
différentes et je suppose que quand il
prépare un adversaire comme kasparov
il doit avoir vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
de travail donc un kasparov ils l'ont
déjà vu pendant six mois quand ils ont
vu pendant six mois mais bon il ya
toujours il est toujours quelque chose à
revoir donc un travail épuisant
à noter donc que joël lautier analyse le
soir avec vladimir c'est parti l'émir
chronique analyse la nuit pour le
préparer l'ouverture de lendemains lui
montre le matin et l'après midi vient
répondre aux questions des journalistes
oui oui un jeu le tir est en pleine
forme j'ai bossé sur vitaminé donc qui
était forcément peut-être un petit peu
fatigué pour cette interview et l'air un
peu fatigué il avait l'air un petit peu
fait il y effectivement donc je le
lotier notre numéro un français qui est
à peu près satisfait de la prestation de
son poulain à l'or fin mai nasa doit il
a dû changer son opinion même nom
vladimir à un accident le jour de
l'interview
c'est à dire qu'il a perdu cette partie
contre boro et beach qui là et qu'il a
un petit peu fait rétrograder au
classement mais
mais bon c'est vrai qu'il a dû être déçu
quand même par cette défaite inattendue
c'est vrai que c'était inattendu
d'autant plus que le mien était très
bien dans l'ouverture morose et ayant
joué une fois de plus quelque chose d'un
peu fantasque dommage en tout cas donc
l'admirent cramique maintenant puisque
c'est indirectement lui qui était
interviewé et se retrouve 4e 6e place
avec 6 points et demi ce qui n'est pas
un bon score évidemment pour le champion
de nombreuses games on enchaîne avec
l'interview donc du jeune hongrois le
numéro un endroit
peter l'écho qui lui rate complètement
son ensemble a donc tout de suite peter
l'écho international chez news by the
eyes of the present sauf mista hôpitaux
locaux des plus soudées kasparov bitchy
of can you say something about vis à vis
à vis fantastique résultat
la capitale échos qui donc un peu
décrochées dans ce tournoi puisque
maintenant il est totalement décontracté
quand on lui parle des résultats du haut
du classement et mehdi à vrai dire je
m'en fous un peu puisque là pour
l'instant j'essaie de finir mon tournoi
en souplesse donc plus tard les côtes
détendu comme et il veut terminer des
salons le tournoi est allé à 100
prochains rendez vous voilà son prochain
rendez vous rappelons effectivement que
le terme rendez-vous est généralement
utilisé pour des rendez vous galants
ce qui explique la surprise de peter
échos notamment
dans le fait qu'il est marié et que sa
femme était juste à côté c'était assez
curieux les poser cette question là en
tout cas maintenant peter l'écho tu le
connais bien laurent puisque je crois
qu'il est il était junior aussi
également votre différence d'âge est
assez réduite
donc est ce que tu essaies de suivre sa
voie sachant que c'est quand même un
excellent j'ai eu un fils il y en aussi
grand serre moi non mais je suis un peu
déçue la callas m 200 m de son attitude
bon ok il a fait un mauvais début mais
il peut quand même essayer de remonter à
plus deux ou plus 3e d'essayer de finir
à peine à la moyenne pour un joueur qui
est qu'elles sont en mission il veut
être champion du monde je sais pas je
trouve pas ça je pense que kasparov qui
fait un tournoi aussi moyens au début
même quand il était jeune il en reste et
de revenir donc je sais pas je trouve ça
un peu dommage
l'écho on l'a souvent considéré comme
étant un joueur peu ambitieux c'est vrai
en tout cas là il se laisse aller 1
puisque il est à -1
quand on dit + 1 - 1 c'est en fait un
score comparatif à la moyenne donc
anthony moins ça veut dire l'équivalent
de que des nuls et une perte donc ça lui
fait cinq points sur 11 dont peter
l'écossé pas bon peut-être qu'il a
passés de motivation en tout cas ils se
réservent pour linares qui sera un autre
grand rendez vous avec les tops mondiaux
il dit qu'il sera mieux préparé qu'il
sera plus en forme rappelant qu'il ait
eu quelques petits problèmes de santé au
cours du champion du monde fim et en
inde ce qui explique peut-être en partie
ses mauvaises performances
maintenant on arrive vers le joueur jean
luc le plus sportif du tournoi le plus
punk chi il s'agit de
vastine topaloff oui donc topalov qui ne
marche pas très bien dans ce tournoi
mais qui qui prend pas mal de risques
comme comme à son habitude avec un jeu
très très intéressant et un joueur très
intéressant également joueur très
intéressant également mons et le numéro
un bulgare depuis très longtemps un
joueur très agressif très impulsif il ya
des avis assez tranché sur beaucoup de
questions tout de suite veselin topalov
international chez news flow of chorus
inde à l'afp présent sauf mystérieuse
line topaloff
alors ça ou là que tu as you want what
what happened in what is khan younis
plein de vie ok so what what you fang
parvenues faisant fi des votes sont en
cause
with the best of 50 like you with french
players un dispositif scor gagne
koudrine de match entre offre et demande
à signer
troisième question de dieu les dames du
fighting to be ok fuck you would i love
vesselin topalov donc qu'est ce qui nous
dit vesselin topalov eh bien ils pensent
que kasparov est encore le meilleur
joueur du monde mais que la différence
rétrécit donc laurent un petit peu comme
toi il a dit vladimir kramnik a
énormément progressé ces deux dernières
années voilà tout à fait il est presque
arrivé au niveau de kasparov il était
très malade en 100 matchs ça c'est clair
et donc il a gagné son match mais bon je
pense que quelque part en faste le
meilleur entourent infirmer
clairement c'est possible jean-luc
vesselin topalov qu'est ce qui t'inspire
d'augustine voilà donc qui a répondu
donc au sujet de crown hic est qu'il ya
des choses intéressantes puisque puisque
l'on y explique vladimir donc
actuellement et est préparée par joël
lautier mais que de toute façon c'est le
joueur qui est capable de battre
kasparov actuellement donc c'est le seul
joueur capable de battre caspar
exactement sinon alors sur la nouvelle
cadence fidh et donc justement ce
raccourcissement des temps de réflexion
qui est imposé et bien mais ce n'était
pas le fait est totalement pour ben
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que il dit maintenant la partie commence
au 20e coup donc c'est pas la peine de
ce conte la tête pendant des heures à
réfléchir puisque l'on joue la théorie
très très vite il faut raccourcir la
durée des parties ça sera plus
spectaculaire et ça sera très très
positif là on va vous demander un avis
laurent moi je pense que c'est peut-être
on peut la raccourcir un petit peu mais
là c'est vraiment trop et je pense que
là la qualité des parties va va
énormément baissé sur le coup et
quelquefois faut voir quand on a vu
kasparov m 20 minutes pour jouer le
premier coup mais peut-être qu'on peut
douter des sports exceptionnellement
effectivement mis 20 minutes pour jouer
son premier coup contre picard l'écho
bon en tout cas vesselin topalov pour
lui c'est très positif
voilà tout ce qu'on peut dire de ce
joueur bulgare très sportif comme il est
tombé ce n'était pas la fille les 9e 11e
4 points et demi donc là si on convertit
ça fait
de petites formes petite forme mais
c'est vrai que ça fait un petit bout de
temps quand même que topalov fait des
mauvais résultats mais super tournant
c'est vrai qu'il avait une grosse
période je crois vers 97 98 tous les
gagner beaucoup de tournants c'est vrai
que là en ce moment il n'est pas à
chaque tournoi il n'est pas il est
toujours au milieu mais en milieu de
classement mais bon c'est pas
c'est un peu décevant mais il semble que
topalov ait eu quelques problèmes pour
revenir à la compétition après après
avoir fait son service militaire
oui c'est vrai que pendant un an il a
arrêté de jouer il est revenu et c'était
tout de suite plus difficile donc
probablement le régime du gard doit être
assez strictes et il n'a pas pu y
échapper le pauvre wesseling instar
évidemment de tous les autres joueurs
d'échecs qui n'ont pas fait leur service
et oui ils ne sont pas citoyens nos amis
j'en ai fait mon service à 5 de la série
maintenant c'est comme ça a changé si
j'ai fait mon service en un jour
d'accord voilà le gros rock et sa
journée citoyenne
on voit tout de suite passé dans un pays
où le service qualité 1 n'est pas
obligatoire donc le joueur est avantagé
il s'agit du grand maître international
flegmatique puisqu'il est anglais manawi
jean-luc michael michael michael adams
donc on va tout de suite le voir news
we have présent sauf comme michael adams
à l'eau michael we like to know how can
you tell me what you résultats in the
world championship in india l'australie
chine a donné ça me file aux 1 2 finales
en investment plos one two days for us
to play
pas de grosse patate
alexei shirov 224 of food extraenergy in
the game because there's something to
prove new french tv programme
britannique spitting denise games in
fine is like the performing one is
painless là que movie acteurs au kef un
clou michael un michael adams
extrêmement détendu comme toujours donc
il a pas mal réussi son début de tournoi
puisqu'il a joué les forts joueurs s'en
est sorti avec +1 avec un arrière-goût
quand même ils donnent ils pensent qu'il
aurait pu gagner plus de parti mais bon
il se dit finalement c'est pas si mal
puisque la fin de tournoi sera plus
facile il lui reste les joueurs les
moins forts à jouer donc il espérait
marquer beaucoup de points enfin les
lois aujourd'hui c'est une journée de
deuil pour michael puisqu'il vient de
perdre contre aleksey fedorov et son
tournoi est un petit peu finir c'est à
dire que c'est une très mauvaise
nouvelle de perdre contre le joueur un
des joueurs a priori les plus faibles
notamment avec les blancs mais en tout
cas michael s'est fait tout simplement
pulvérisé oui ça arrive même aux joueurs
les plus solides puisque pour l'instant
il n'est pas perdu deux parties donc il
est très très calme de michael adams on
voit par exemple en réponse à la
question est ce que garry kasparov fait
du cinéma un peu comme un acteur
de cinéma justement lorsqu'il commence à
marcher à regarder avec ses tics nerveux
et michael répond tout simplement now
bah non en fait il pense pas ils pensent
que kasparov essayez quelque part d'une
certaine manière de déconcentrer ses
adversaires en tout cas de perturber le
le
de perturber ses adversaires c'est ce
qu'il explique non non non je disais
tout est fluide venait boston shawn qui
veut dire donc de se débarrasser de la
tension nerveuse mais bon tu peux
interpréter ça puisque effectivement
chalutier michael ont des rapports assez
proche donc potache pierre bemba soit le
style une intervention déclarations à
l'ana michael tu as tu as quand même
battus ou biya oui effectivement nous
sommes sortis ensuite dans un bar avec
michael adams
décidément c'est quand même michael
adams et yann timone sont les deux
joueurs les plus cools entre guillemets
du tournoi donc michael et comme
cinquième ou sixième joueur mondial
yann timberland ème joueur mondial 4e
joueur mondial et dont nous avons passé
avec une soirée assez sympathique
michael boit beaucoup et ensuite il a
joué au billard le billard est un jeu
anglais
il est quand même très fort il joue très
très bien et il ya talentueux parce
qu'en fait il a progressé pendant la
partie donc c'est enfin bref ça dépasse
un peu le cadre des échecs enfin michael
adams est très calme très tranquille pas
du tout méchant il a l'air très gentil
et pourtant c'est quand même un qui leur
est pourtant il est très efficace très
efficace donc michael adams qu'on a vu
ici lors on est ce que c'est ce que tu
as un avis sur michael moi je pense
qu'il joue très bien d'ailleurs il
maï-maï matures en match je peux rien et
en l'autre et j'ai rencontré au grand
prix de bordeaux ce sera leur grand plus
de bordeaux donc j'avais mon c'était pas
très impressionnant mais c'était c'est
comme dans son style d'habitude ils ont
que c'est pas très très impressionnant
ya passé pas du style kasparov avec 17
suffisait tout ça mais c'est un petit
cri vissage tout au long de la partie et
voilà et à la fin on a l'impression
qu'il n'ya pas trop rien qu'il a qu'il
n'a pas fait grand chose mais il gagne
et c'est le plus important
oui kasparov avait décrit son style
également de la même façon en dix ans le
style un petit peu langoureux
un serpent un serpent ou une sorte de
symbole voilà donc michael adams qui
pour l'instant a donc six points sur 11
c'est pas c'est pas très bon pour le 4e
mondial petite forme peut-être il a eu
une petite phrase marrante aussi pour en
finir avec michael j'étais un peu déçu
de mon dernier match aux championnats du
monde fis d mais comme c'est un système
car ce n'est pas surprenant
c'est vrai que quand il ya 100 joueurs
il y en à 99 qui finissent par perdre
leurs derniers matches oui donc
évidemment ça fait 1 % de joueurs
satisfaits de leur dernier match c'était
en l'occurrence wichmann anand dernière
interview on a gardé le meilleur pour la
fin le meilleur entre guillemets puisque
il est deuxième du tournoi actuellement
il s'agit du jeune russe alexander
morozevich tout de suite bientôt
nationale chez news alexander morozevich
un hello alexandre soon as you just beat
vladimir kramnik it's fantastic résulte
de vote on utilise changing compliqué ça
donne i can't you explain game of today
soit les chenilles reach chronique
touffue of plague lovers and for space
sommet bi know you want me to define the
cause of creativity to play new morning
canigou distribuer au kef un cube
voilà donc c'est terminé pour alexander
morozevich enfin c'est terminé pour
cette interview en tout cas donc qu'est
ce qu'ils pensent de son tournoi il
pensait qu'il lui restait quatre parties
à jouer et qu'il avait envie de les
jouer tranquillement à noter que malgré
ses airs tranquilles c'est bien une bête
de travail jean luc oui c'est une bête
de travail et il est extrêmement
extrêmement stressé donc probablement
par son travail quand tu l'as vu sortir
de sa partie contre krainik donc ramené
qui était complètement abattu et est
morose et vite chaud si tremblay et où
c'était vraiment un choc de titans
d'ailleurs l'interview a été faite juste
après la partie on l'a attrapée à la
sortie de la partie on a pratiquement
porter jusqu'à la caméra il était
vraiment immédiatement accusé il était
en état de choc
il était en état de choc en tout cas il
a battu vladimir kramnik ce qui est pas
mal
à la question est-ce qu'il est plus
ambitieux maintenant eh bien il répond
donc simplement que j'ai quatre parties
à jouer et je compte bien jouer
tranquillement alors on remarque
peut-être pour laurent il a parlé de son
style ouverture et il a dit qu'il avait
régulièrement des positions qu'ils
avaient l'air très mauvaise mais que
c'était pas sûr qu est ce que tu en
penses
bah disons c'est vrai que ça a l'air
très mauvais mais bon c'est ces patients
non plus et qu'il a une imagination
complètement les peu style un peu foufou
et donc c'est vrai que c'est ces cinq
sets c'est toujours intéressant de
regarder nos regardez c'est parti et
c'est vrai qu'il peut battre n'importe
qui et la preuve c'est qu'il a battu
chrome ni qui a permis à une partie
depuis 81 parties je prends le
dans les territoires de top niveau donc
c'est vrai que c'est calme c'est très
impressionnant et c'est que ce style là
il peut battre n'importe qui mais bon il
peut perdre contre n'importe qui use des
bretons qui je m'entends il peut dans ce
tournoi et il peut il peut très bien
perdre contre n'importe
c'est possible oui c'est vrai que moi
aux évite ch et quand même pas stable il
est pour le moins instable et donc là en
tout cas ça marche pas mal
on rappelle qu'il avait déjà été en tête
je crois au tournoi de sarajevo où il
avait très bien marché avec kasparov et
shirov ils étaient 3 1 il y avait
également michael adams et sur la fin de
tournoi marseillais qui s'était tout
simplement des composés il avait
commencé à enchaîner les défaites et
donc n'avait pas terminé le classement
tel qu'il était en cours de tournoi donc
là espérons enfin il ya plus de deux
rondes à tenir après tout pour moi on
s'est vite et il peut faire probablement
le meilleur résultat de sa carrière
voilà tout à fait on peut dire qu'il est
comme beaucoup de joueurs il est un
complexe gaz par an des jo avec les
blancs comme kasparov qui a fait nul en
casse cou mais c'est vrai que quand on
regarde ces dernières parties compterait
cependant je crois qu'il n'a pas gagné
une
et il avait perdu 5 ou 6 sur une dizaine
de partis donc c'est vrai c'est un sport
où est donc en fait il a pris une
décision pratique il s'est dit j'ai les
blancs je n'ai pas essayé de je vais pas
essayer donc encore une fois de me
prendre une grosse tôle
je vais plutôt essayer de la jouer
décontracté solide et donc c'est ce
qu'il a fait il a fait nul kasparov lui
a reproché via son site internet
il ya dix morose et beach t il formaté
par un sapeur dgo tu me dégoûtes je
crois que morose et vie de chat bien
choisi il aurait même d'ailleurs dû
employer cette stratégie dès les
premiers matches car quand on joue
contre kasparov
il est très très important de commencer
par des matches nuls à avant de perdre
oui en fait c'est comme 14 c'est un peu
comme entrer dans une baignoire
bouillante
il vaut mieux mettre un pied d'abord
plutôt que de plonger dedans exactement
autant que les galeries la baignoire
gary la baignoire on va commenter en
bref pour terminer cette émission avant
donc la petit bêtisier de ce reportage
et bien on va rappeler les classements
kasparov premier avec 8 points shirov
morose à bitche qui le suivent un point
derrière puisqu'ils ont sept points sur
travnik allende et yvan lachaud qui vend
le show qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé
mais il a quand même six points et demi
donc il est en 4ème 6ème position c'est
pas si mal
michael adams 6.1 peter l'écho cinq
points 8e 9e 11e topalov fedorov et
vendent des lits ensuite y'a timan qui
est en train de s'écrouler complètement
à quatre points pickett et yves yaacov
trois points et demi c'est probablement
les deux joueurs les plus faibles du
tournoi à noter que pic attendu ne
recueille autant de mieux quand même
oui tibia cov de loin le plus faible du
tournoi mais pic est quand même en
petite forme capable de faire beaucoup
mieux
piquette nantes avait notamment battu
kasparov au grand prix kasparov
d'ailleurs il est battu sur son terrain
le tournoi sur internet donc là on vous
a préparé une petite séquence
décontracté qui montrait que ce voyage
était assez tranquille donc on va
l'envoyer tout de suite voilà le
bêtisier wichmann des fêtes de wisches
kenzy en hollande où se déroule
actuellement le plus fort tournoi
d'échecs jamais joué de tous les temps
avec donc je coupe du canal tv
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs nous sommes une activi
l'actualité internationale du jeu des
nativi l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
nous sommes en direct de wisches kenzy
en hollande où nous pouvons assister aux
plus forts joueurs eux aux ego nativi
l'actualité internationale jeu d'échecs
nous sommes en direct de wisches kenzy
en hollande où nous pouvons assister aux
plus forts tournoi d'échecs de tous les
temps avec les quatre prétendants à cet
assaut alors la loi
so we are in direct live from my kenzy
inde jean luc et de vertolaye because
garry kasparov et playing games alexei
shirov ça se comprend facilement aussi
des traits fatigués après son champion
du monde
dit donald heavy l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs bonjour joël diagonale
l'actualité du jeu d'échecs
nous sommes ici avec le numéro un
français joël lautier bonjour joël à
l'actualité du jeu d'échecs
nous sommes ici avec joël lautier le
numéro un français qui se marrent
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs
nous sommes ici à wisches kenzy avec
joël lautier numéro un français bonjour
joël bonjour voilà finalement il a
réussi il a réussi joël lautier à noter
que on le sait ne connaissais pas comme
ça puisque dans le mot il est très calme
très posé et ça n'arrive jamais jean-luc
ouais c'est vrai c'est très curieux je
crois que j'ai réussi à faire craquer
joël voilà donc ici on a fait craquer
joël laurent bas merci d'être d'avoir
participé à cette émission
merci à toi et bonne continuation donc
de toute façon dont ces prochains
tournois
jean-luc merci également donc
prochain rendez vous lundi dans la leçon
oui donc je donne rendez vous aux
téléspectateurs de canal web donc pour
une leçon sur
sur la défense pire voilà merci et la
semaine prochaine